[Música]
y yo lamento hablar de revista de prensa
hoy martes 8 de marzo con rosa pérez
masdéu rosa bienvenida además feliz día
de la mujer un gusto compartir con usted
todas las mañanas informando a toda
nuestra audiencia
precisamente abrimos esta revista de
prensa con una pieza audiovisual del
diario el país se ministra en pie de
guerra lucha de las soldadas ucranianas
buenos días raúl las gracias por la
felicitación
exactamente esta es una pieza de ibai
arbide y adriana cardoso como comentabas
para el país en el que ambos periodistas
van al encuentro de anna y anastasía
ellas son dos enfermeras que desde que
estalló la guerra en el donbass hace
ocho años se alistaron como voluntarias
en las fuerzas armadas de ucrania ellas
se definen como feministas nacionalistas
y de izquierdas y rechazan que el rol de
la mujer quede relegado a la retaguardia
y cuando les pregunta el periodista
sobre si tienen miedo de enfrentarse al
que es el segundo mayor ejército del
mundo aclara el periodista una pregunta
que le haría también a cualquier hombre
soldado
ya sé escuchemos lo que responde en raúl
[Música]
y dejamos a un lado el país rosa para ir
al espectador en colombia donde
encontramos también a mujeres ucranianas
sin aportar su edición digital dice
mujeres las más desplazadas por la
guerra en ucrania no están en las
negociaciones
exactamente maría alejandra medina nos
aporta algunos datos sobre la situación
en ucrania con perspectiva de género nos
recuerda que las fuerzas armadas de
ucrania están compuestas en un 10 por
ciento por mujeres y que fue
precisamente la guerra en el donbass la
que obligó al ejército ucraniano a
acabar con la discriminación que
imperaba en esas fuerzas armadas porque
hasta recientemente las mujeres no
podían ocupar ciertos cargos dentro del
ejército como por ejemplo ser
francotirador as también recuerda este
artículo que el 75% de las personas
desplazadas del país pues son también
mujeres pero es que recordemos que esto
se explica en gran parte porque los
hombres de entre 16 y 60 años no pueden
abandonar el país y bien lo que también
señala esta periodista es que las
mujeres que se quedan en un territorio
ucraniano quedan a menudo al frente de
lo que es la retaguardia y la
organización de la ayuda de la
organización humanitaria digamos por lo
que señala que naciones unidas- critica
que el hecho que las mujeres no estén en
las negociaciones supone pues un vacío a
la hora de abordar las cuestiones
humanitarias que atañen a los civiles en
esta en este conflicto bajo esta
invasión rusa de ucrania y rosa en el
salto diario podemos escuchar una
entrevista a dos activistas de los
derechos humanos que narran la situación
desde y también de esa efectivamente
esta es una entrevista que dura 40
minutos en la que daría lo vano va desde
hardcore y evelyn a gastar ya desde
odessa cuentan cómo es el día a día bajo
esta invasión rusa y ellas también se
definen como feministas y también como
pacifistas pero señalan pues que es muy
difícil no la organicen cya no violenta
no armada en este contexto y de hecho
les preguntan por este auge del
nacionalismo ucraniano y este nazismo
contra el que putin supuestamente quería
acabar a la hora de invadir este país y
también si te parece escuchemos una
pedazo de lo que responde daría lo ganó
va
yo puedo decir que hay un auge de
nacionalismo asismo podemos ver que en
la misma defensa territorial que son
personas que no son militares podemos
ver que participan tanto gente de la
izquierda de la derecha
anarquistas y nacionalistas las personas
homófobos lfp y en vez de dividirnos por
lo que nos querían perseguir por el auge
del nacionalismo han hecho que esta
gente se ha adjuntado porque ahora
tienen un objetivo
el objetivo rosa de defender su país de
esta guerra y cerramos con imágenes de
fotografías de algunas periodistas sobre
el terreno rosa exactamente hemos hecho
una pequeñísima selección pues porque no
teníamos tiempo de mostrar más pero les
animamos a buscar en redes sociales en
medios de comunicación veíamos una
imagen de maría saurí yo la corresponsal
de el país en moscú en el sabor y allá
donde pues se incendió esa central
nuclear que puso en vilo a media europa
donde había coronas fúnebres para los
ocupantes
también lynsey addario en la que fue
esta la portada del new york times' en
irving donde se ven los cadáveres de una
familia que intentaba huir del país
cuando les alcanza un mortero ruso el
domingo 6 de marzo también vemos esta
imagen del mismo momento hemos señalado
también
fotografías de nicole atún para harper's
donde vemos aquí a cientos de personas
en también la estación de tren de irvine
intentando huir del país en este mismo
contexto una pareja se despide también
el 4 de marzo vemos pues la madre que se
va con el hijo de 11 meses mientras pues
el hombre se queda digamos en territorio
ucraniano y terminamos con esas imágenes
de él interjet para bloomberg del metro
convertido pues en un refugio antiaéreo
que triste esas imágenes rosa gracias
por toda la información feliz día
nuevamente mañana nos vemos con más de
revista de prensa pasamos a saludar a
nuestra primera invitada al día